si vous êtes un farouche opposant aux
vaccins en tout genre vous serez
désormais persona non grata sur facebook
avec 2,7 milliards d'utilisateurs actifs
par mois sur sa plateforme
le géant des réseaux sociaux qui a
longtemps hésité à supprimer les
contenus anti vaccins pour ne pas se
transformer en arbitre des fausses
informations a fini par céder aux
pressions des législateurs et des
groupes de santé publique
notre objectif est de contribuer à ce
que les messages sur la sécurité et
l'efficacité des vaccins atteignent une
large tranche de personnes désormais si
une annonce décourage explicitement
quelqu'un à se faire vacciner
oula roger tron dans un message publié
le 13 octobre le groupe fait savoir
qu'il lancera même une campagne
d'information pour encourager ses
utilisateurs à se faire vacciner alors
que les experts en santé publique
s'accordent à dire que nous ne
disposerons pas dit si un moment d'un
vaccin disponible à grande échelle
contre lakovic 19
nous pouvons prendre des mesures pour
rester en bonne santé et en sécurité
cela inclut de se faire vacciner contre
la grippe saisonnière il faut dire que
l'épidémie de couronnes 1 virus à
relancer la vigueur des militants anti
vaccination sur les réseaux sociaux
alors que les sociétés pharmaceutiques
se sont lancés dans une course contre la
montre pour trouver la formule gagnante
contre le colis de 19 les antilles dax
comme on les appelle sont de plus en
plus nombreux les personnes sceptiques à
l'égard des vaccins parce qu adepte des
médecines naturelles se retrouve
désormais dans le même camp que des
citoyens inquiets pour leurs libertés
fondamentales parmi les arguments ce qui
revient souvent c'est une défiance
globale vis-à-vis des pouvoirs publics
mais aussi de l'industrie pharmaceutique
et il faut dire que de récentes
révélations n'aide pas à améliorer
l'image de big pharma le surnom donné au
géant de cette industrie en effet le
financial times vient de révéler une
information qui démontre comment
certains d'entre eux cherchent à
maximiser les profits même en temps de
crise le journal anglais a découvert un
tour de passe-passe du groupe
pharmaceutique britannique astrazeneca
qui bénéficie de fonds publics du
gouvernement américain et d'un
partenariat avec l'université d'oxford
qui s'était engagé à rendre un vaccin
contre le coc u19 accessible et à un
prix raisonnable dans le monde entier
des licences qui autorise la fabrication
et la distribution du fameux vaccin ont
d'ores et déjà été signés donc plusieurs
régions du monde comme l'amérique du sud
notamment où plusieurs pays pourront
produire des centaines de millions de
doses qui seront vendus à deux ou trois
euros l'unité
problème le financial times dévoile
l'existence d'un accord commercial signé
entre le géant pharmaceutique est un
producteur brésilien où on apprend qu'en
réalité ces petits prix ne seront
pratiquées que jusqu'à la fin de la
pandémie que le laboratoire astrazeneca
fixe avec un formidable don de voyance à
juin 2021
à partir de cette date pour le moins
optimiste est totalement arbitraire le
géant pharmaceutique comptes repasser sa
potion aux prix du marché
les accords entre big pharma et les
états qui demeure strictement
confidentielle octroie un contrôle
inacceptable aux firmes pharmaceutiques
sur des vaccins développés grâce à des
fonds publics compter sur les
engagements volontaires des
multinationales pour assurer l'accès
universel aux vaccins c'est une erreur
qui aura des conséquences dramatiques
de quoi nourrir le scepticisme des anti
vaccins sur les réseaux sociaux
jusqu'à présent facebook supprimait
uniquement les contenus propageant de
fausses informations liées aux vaccins
en se fondant sur l'avis d'organisations
considérées comme des autorités comme
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
le réseau social tient tout de même à
rassurer ses utilisateurs il sera
toujours autorisé de se positionner pour
ou contre les législations ou les
décisions gouvernementales au sujet des
vaccins
pas sûr que cette nuance suffisent à
mieux faire passer la pilule auprès des
anti vaccins